sometimes I remind myself that I need to
be more like my so in year-old self
because she didn't really care well what
do you want to do in life I was
terrified of that question for a very
very long time if you would have asked
like 8-year old me I wanted to dance oh
I wanted to be a florist it was 18 19 I
wanted to be an actress so I I tried out
for theater school because that's the
path that I thought you would have to go
through I tried out the four times and I
did not get in I actually then thought
that that was probably gonna be it and
it was not until I got one phone call
and I chose to go in for a casting and
then I realized that life will just take
you on a journey and if you're kind of
open up trying as much things as
possibly then hopefully you'll just end
up going on the right path it can be a
lot of talk about what is it that you're
gonna achieve next for me um I love the
fact that I maybe don't know what I'm
doing in ten years they might come up
other things that I will be interested
in that I kind of just hope but I will
have the courage and debt maybe throw
myself out and other things that I
haven't done before that would be cool
sometimes I remind myself that I need to
be more like my seven-year-old self
because she didn't really care she just
did and and sometimes I I think I wake
up now I tried to think things over a
bit too much but my seven-year-old self
mostly seemed to want to do the things
that were fun we need the Oscars it's
it's still every time I get reminded of
it it feels like this is a real
experience but I'm still young and I
really just see it as the nicest biggest
tap on the shoulder that you're heading
at the right direction
so you need to keep it up and always
just try and push yourself further and
enjoy the journey
you